there are over a hundred different
modifiers for test your lung and of
course you can select how many you want
to have active during the match we're
just gonna go ahead and get into it I'll
be fairly ok Laki going back to your
grappling routes
I am so yeah you can the number default
is 5 but of course you can select 5 6 7
3 but oh no let's let 4 let's do 4 go to
see how four does once you start getting
into 7 it gets really chaotic this is
create this is one of those kind of
really great game times for the guys
like when you're having you know a party
having the guys over and you're gonna
like sit on the couch and play some fun
stuff this can get ridiculous and fun
and just you're always laughing and you
never know what's gonna happen know the
best part and the cool thing that I
really like is there's a lot of
modifiers that aren't just difficult
they actually can help you right there's
more assists yes there's a bunch of
really fun it's just one soon and we
don't have intros to talk to you know
intros intros intros so you can talk us
through we'll see what were these duties
absolutely do and they might not
necessarily apply to both of you yeah
which is one of the other fun things
there's nothing to yell action
ok so portal combat portals will
randomly appear infinite timer which is
good so if I know enhanced specials for
you and the curse of slaw so that little
school that drunk ever make whatever
slow absolutely alright cool so here we
go gah oh I was catching the compost oh
I'm super slow oh I love you could use
extra combos out of the truth oh yeah
because it changes the
I'll come right into it portal yeah it
was badass
which is so good
Oh Thank You Tyler ha you brought me to
another win these are Kemp please do not
care about this count test your luck
counts it does not dogskin up the cavity
good oh no you jumped away after oh no
that was hubris but of course you can
combo off of them
you can block a lot of the modifiers as
well so it's not like oh portal killed
me but all right so then you'll notice
you can rematch new modifiers you can
remand with the same modifiers if you
want to just run it back you just want
to do new yeah okay so we're going to
show just a couple of these matches on
electric fists so after X amount of hits
it's going to go into electric stun the
magnetic floor and a closer compass hand
close con w got tunnel damage this could
be met if I lose this I'm not ready to
the yeah
oh yes this is fun Winchester play we
play no no I need her Farah or Blanche
it looks like both Oh No what's up
fairness it's just chillin on your
folder I love that pose it's kind of
like a pet like a parrot yeah you want
to do one more one more one more
all right and then we'll go into our
next game mode whichever I have it I'm
going to I have an idea I heard of that
all right so fire rockets I'm guessing
there's a rocket rate of fire yes okay
okay look that was a projectile you know
what have been awesome to reflect Farrah
back frost touch yes all right so here
we go
this is something I love it
even these first seven rows we have in
hospital beds of course is it double
date for photos yeah goodness house
wondering how it's done
oh and that that was really fast
yeah look how mad he is or happy no
matter I think he's just excited
does he have a notion that your question
yeah he talks just can't understand it
no perfect thank you for the help Steve
it was worthless so we'll go into our
next game mother this week a good time
to say something oh okay oh yeah so just
to let you all know for Mortal Kombat X
we will be supporting judging of the
camera awesome five sticks for a ps4 yes
have us four fights to get the old
Mortal Kombat sitting the day that's
three Mortal Kombat stick we also via of
course the Justice one from injustice so
yeah so if you have a ps4 we it is
supported to your sticks and we thought
it'd be fun to play game with Derek
using stick cuz there it doesn't use
stick and me not using stick there's a
now it's very I think that's fun I think
it's fine I'll play Johnny Cage why
don't play very much you play him
actually quite often I've actually
played your Johnny Cage okay guys let's
be cool so for a custom combat you
actually get to pick the modifiers that
you want active
you can actually select if you want them
to affect just the opponent both players
or just assist yourself you can go with
selecting no modifiers and it'll just
select randomize how do you unlock these
modifiers you ask I didn't though okay
um you complete our living Towers the
hourly living tower after you complete
it you'll unlock that modifier so
naturally all these will not be unlocked
but there are quite a few stuff you can
pick your stuff - man I'm gonna go mmm
I'm gonna go with the Cabal assist okay
I'm just gonna give that to me that's
fine I'm gonna do the godfist for both
of us or just you I'll do it for both of
us because I'm generous sometimes okay
so God Fitz is if a little trinket will
fall yes if you grab it you can kill
them immediately yes it is basically an
instant kill unless they block it then
it just takes 50% of their last very
shortly yes it's only about a second and
a half so it's a I gave you killer jumps
thanks what does that do i if it's
killer jumps yeah I'll probably kill you
with jump attacks well bad jumping that
will damage me every time I know I do
the other one oh thank you Oh No
okay I'm gonna do double fence dangerous
team okay yeah do you want to get crazy
oh oh you're gonna back out you're gonna
change your choices
why did you wrong oh nothing just go
down so yes yeah just there you go
actually as I didn't confirm Oh wasn't
you owes me oops so I gave him the wrong
thing so I'm gonna get killed pretty
quickly his jump attacks will now kill
you
yeah great idea Tyler well he's using a
stick that I was to tell you to pick the
one where his jump attacks will hurt him
right so I might jump it kick it hurts
me so I misheard you
yeah yeah okay are you guys teaming up
yes like obviously not it seems like it
all right here we go all right yes okay
good
in action that's good yeah see ya
I win again this is great
well crap um let's do it
it won't do model come by the president
that back that was great guys you're
much better on the arcade stick than I
thought you'd be yeah
thank you I don't think you can do with
any other character but all right well I
guess I'll try it see how it works I'll
do brawler Cassie cage now that's I'm
not gonna be a total ass to you I'm
gonna because it backfired completely
what you think Steve you can't go wrong
with cyrex bombs okay I'm going to do
I'm gonna do Sarge bombs for both
players oh that is kind of you it's in
my life I will do rain bubbles bubbles
oh nice nice yeah okay then I'll do I
gotta do somethin tempo to juggle do
juggle juggle so much come on do general
how you say how many there are there's a
whole bunch there is a ridiculous amount
to say on over a hundred coke and let's
do x-ray insta-kill let's see how that
works
not so fun really good yeah okay cool
okay Oh No hold on I did this only for
me and that's that's not cool okay so
this is a really good couch combat type
of thing absolutely and this this mode
is only exclusive to local online yeah
so you can't you know go online and play
this all right we got some fun tends to
go through here
look oh you feel if I win again I'm so
used to it yes like it's fine yeah yeah
you don't even get emo anymore I don't
you do online
okay okay yeah that's the last one yeah
like you're sad your face was so sad
people took pictures of it I know
and they made like little montages are
you crying it's so good
the best part was how you immediately
came to QA lab to tell me about how you
weren't emo right oh you only put it on
player 2 for java combat I didn't mean -
you're such a bad friend
what do you mean we're friends all right
I keep thinking that I can run they'll
kill you
no no get them follow no wind go team
I didn't mean to I didn't mean to be
hands down awesome I really like that
Phil that pops I'll write it for that
box get in that bubble nope oh thanks
for making that for both of us I'm so
right now I mean just how you should
yeah that's awesome